let me start by saying how much I loved
the movie and congratulations thank you
this was your first big leading role in
a big superhero movie well first leading
role in any feature-length I mean there
was in movie theatres you know what I
mean
I played the leading role in some movies
that weren't in movie theaters and I've
been in movies that have been in movie
theaters and I wasn't the title
character by a long shot so this is huge
yeah and that it's a superhero movie is
even bigger than that
I'm just curious being everyone has told
me who's an actor it's like they say
making a boo movie like this is like
making a marathon like you have to run a
marathon and I'm just curious did you
look - did you talk to any friends who
are actors like ask for advice in terms
of like how to sort of maintain yourself
for the entirety of a big shoot no I
probably should have done no I mean I
definitely I've known well like when I
did Thor I was I saw Chris do it I
didn't need to I'd you know when I got
this I already knew I saw what Chris's
line was and how the dedication and that
being in the gym and then the calories
he was eating and all of the things that
he needed to do to bring that character
to life so you know moments friends like
that that I've seen over the years pop
and grab these roles and flourish in
them and so I think I had a somewhat of
an idea but nobody can really fully
prepare you because also all the roles
are slightly different as well and they
demand very different things from you
fortunately I mean genuinely like I
can't believe I'm so lucky that I get to
play the kid in the superhero and
therefore not have to restrain my
enthusiasm at all in fact just allow it
all to be because you know a lot Chris
I'm sure was beyond stoked when he was
Thor but Thor's gotta be you're a
serious you know so does cap so does
Batman super I mean most of them have to
be very serious these are real stakes as
real responsibilities Billy doesn't feel
that response
he just feels the optimism and so that's
a different track I I couldn't ask
anybody on the creative side other than
maybe Tom Hanks what was it like doing
big you know I didn't have anybody to
draw from on that side and on the
physical side of things it's pretty much
just like you know you go sit down with
any trainer and be like hey I want to go
and become this and they go great well
when you want to start cuz you're gonna
be in the gym six days a week and you
can eat I didn't do to do two days
you're gonna eat tons and tons of
calories and supplements and but gret
awesome I feel better than I've ever
felt in my life and now I get to open a
huge superhero it's amazing I I'm very
curious the superhero genre the comic
book movie if you will is the most
popular genre on the planet right now
what do you think it is about the
superhero movie that is resonates with
so many people well I think we're
finally in you know just a time of like
technology where we are able to make
superhero movies properly far more
properly than I think we were able to do
in the past because special effects are
just so good so I think a lot of people
are now able to appreciate the story
more than let's say twenty years ago
when they're looking at a go another
kind that might look cheesy or they
might look this and they might look that
so I'm just on a technical level we're
able to make them in a very great way I
think as far as the stories that are
within all of these IPS I mean I think
pop culture has finally caught up on
what a lot of us you know kids who read
comics have always known which is that
these are really awesome stories these
are the classic hero archetypes and and
also do you know comics have always been
subversive and they go into areas and
talk about things that sometimes you
know your other other media or content
don't go in and tap into because you
have there's a Liberty in that because
you're you know ink on paper and that's
its it there's art involved in it and so
you know I know a lot of people within
the the world
I've gotten a little let's say I don't
want a possessive but you know it's not
like all of a sudden you know Henry
Cavill as Superman and a bunch of girls
do think he's gorgeous are now suddenly
into Superman and then there's diehard
Superman fans are like who are these
johnny-come-lately 'he's that are all of
a sudden liking Superman it's like
that's not a bad thing exactly that's a
great thing it's great that people now
see the thing that we always saw that we
always loved we saw Clark Kent and Bruce
Wayne and Peter Parker and Billy Batson
we saw all of them and we saw ourselves
in all of them and that's not changed
those stories all have been there we're
just now finally able to make them like
put them on screen in really cool ways
and so people that aren't comic book
lovers from the get-go are still just
gonna appreciate it regardless because
it's a good movie gotta go yeah
congratulations seriously you did such
an awesome job thank you
you